I think in five years or so VR is going
to be a really prominent platform for
experiences for business for commerce
entertainment social let me tell you why
so I've been trying a lot of the VR gear
and the thing about VR is and the other
version of it called mr mixed reality
which is where you see virtual objects
in the real world and VR where you see
only the virtual world
both of those operate on a different
part of your brain then when you're
watching on a screen so a very common
demonstration in VR is to put on a pair
of goggles while you're in a room and
then to drop the virtual floor inside
away so you're suddenly standing on a
cliff and ask you to walk out on a plank
that's over nothing maybe it's
kilometers deep and for most people you
can't it's almost impossible do your
knees start shaking you're nauseous even
while your brain is telling you hey
you're doing the same room I was in a
few moments ago the VR is working on a
lower different part of your brain stem
so much more primeval
as part of it that experiences things
and when you take your VR goggle off you
remember not having seen something but
having experienced it and that ability
to get to where we feel things get to
where we experience things is very very
powerful and in trying many many of
these worlds for almost two decades or
more one of the things that's most
surprising to me is that the most
intriguing things in these worlds are
not incredible objects or not amazing
world there are actually other people
so when you have a world with other
people in it that's really what's the
most powerful thing and we now have the
ability to add a couple things to make
those people seeing real one of them is
eye contact
the other one is ability to have
real-time capture of their movements so
you can see and see the body language
and you can detect it back actually this
other person and the experience is a
real experience and that experience of
other people I think is going to make VR
the most social of all the social media
and actually been trying a couple of
these VR games where you have to do
stuff physically and even the idea that
this is sort of you're going to become a
big slug in the closet is isolated is
totally wrong this is going to be some
of the most calisthenic kinetic activity
that we're going to undergo VR is likely
to become the social platform within
five years and it's the place we're
going to download exchange buy purchase
experiences which are going to be some
of the most valuable things that we can
create and there'll be a whole economy
based around this and then the amount of
data that is necessary to make this work
is huge there's going to be no VR
without AI and the VR companies who make
this are going to become the largest
data companies in the world because in
order to have your avatar in the VR in
real time you have to capture so much of
our behavior that we're going to be
capturing behavior that's expensive to
capture outside in the real world that's
going to be very cheap to capture in VR
and the companies that are running these
they're not making the money selling
goggles they're going to be collecting
our lives data and that's going to be
there well part of the attraction for
business in VR is going to be the fact
that everything is quantified that
everything is digitized and our digital
lives are going to become
paramount there and so the issues about
who owns that data the issues of who
controls that data the issue is about
what can be done with it will continue
to loom and the power of what you can do
with that will be harnessed by AI
because that data alone is just a
headache without ai and that promise of
having a virtual life is going to be I
think the big thing in business in five
years
[Music]